people had the greatest hooks of all
time and it died in their notepad
because they weren't able to cook the
whole meal they had the hook or they had
the first right one of the things I've
been trying to get some up-and-coming
artists to really debate is like if
you're sitting with something fire but
you can't figure out the rest of it that
should be the tick tock make it a
challenge you never know which producer
hits you up you have no idea of some
next great ghost writers out there
watching your season in their for
you page you know not like the first day
because you got to play with it for a
minute but like if you're like damn I've
been stuck with this hook for six months
I ain't do with it let me just put
it out